el equipo de defensa del expresidente de
Perú Pedro Castillo está de gira por
Europa en un viaje sufragado por
colectivos peruanos tras visitar Ginebra
donde presentaron el caso de Castillo
ante el grupo de trabajo detenciones
arbitrarias de la ONU el abogado
Wilfredo Robles hizo parada en Madrid
ahí habló acerca de la nueva solicitud
de prisión preventiva de 36 meses que
podría decidirse este jueves
la brutalidad del sistema penal peruano
que hoy está capturado por la dictadura
a Pedro Castillo no le han respetado el
ante juicio político que ordena la
constitución
entonces son juicios políticos
no están basados en normas legales
durante toda la conferencia Robles se
refirió al actual gobierno de Dina
boluarte como una dictadura que no sirve
al pueblo peruano en este sentido sobre
las decenas de víctimas mortales que ha
causado la fuerte represión policial en
Perú el abogado lamentó la falta de
solidaridad mundial y comparó este caso
con la indignación global tras el
asesinato de la afro estadounidense
George Floyd en 2020 nosotros
ya tenemos en el Perú más de 70 George
Floyd pero no vemos ese mismo nivel de
indignación
la Unión Europea no se pronuncia los
organismos de Derechos Humanos no se
pronuncian los gobiernos las cadenas de
prensa mundial
O es que O es que en la vida de los
quechuas y los aymaras no vale tanto yo
creo que sí para la defensa de Castillo
la única manera de que se dé un proceso
con garantías democráticas en Perú para
el expresidente y los demás detenidos
solo Será posible con la salida de
dinavoluarte del Poder y la disolución
del Congreso actual
martillo amigo